it we got we got breaking news Katie  Hobbs has won Arizona reports decision  desk that they have flipped the  Republican state Democrat as of 8 50 p.m  with 98 reporting Carrie Lake was still  down and unable to win there were not  enough remaining votes so uh they're  calling it what do you think Carrie is  going to do I don't think she's going to  take this line down she better not uh I  think she's gonna file some lawsuits  they they absolutely should she has  standing here and she has to move very  very quickly on this one uh look if the  people of Arizona legally respectfully  voted for Katie Hobbs uh so be it so be  it uh but in today's day and age with  the way this country is going uh Carey  Lake absolutely should not and in order  to solve the problem of 2020 and now  2022 with ballot harvesting and  Universal mail-in voting the long lines  the adjudication the broken machines you  need standing and that standing just  happened right now